we really wanted to pay respects to what
came before
we're actually standing on the shoulders
of giants and now it's for us to
actually
broaden that out and carry the dream
with us
i mean when i see you guys both in this
movie because kung lao
and liu kang are a great duo together i
was like this casting is
immaculate perfect for any actor to to
to actually play any role but especially
something so iconic
and so enduring to myself it's
definitely up there
i mean it's a dream role come true
also one of the first well the first big
role for me
and being part of such a big hollywood
film is just
overwhelming and it's a opportunity that
i'm
very grateful for there's a lot of
really great source material for mortal
kombat not limited to
the 90s movie which holds a special
place in a lot of our hearts are you
guys
a fan of those movies and what do you
think the biggest
differences between what we've seen back
then and what we're seeing now obviously
the improvement of technology has
added to our benefit um for the film
but um speaking for myself i've been a
huge fan of the first model combat film
in that came out in 95 and
having an asian lead as you know the
main the main character
uh back then was robin xiao and i think
what makes
this film um mortal kombat 21
so special is that now we have a whole
ensemble of
asian actors who are representing and
this kind of
i mean you have crazy rich asians which
is
a comedic or romantic
kind of movie and then now you have more
combat
which is the opposite but we're still
representing and
i just love that i i don't think
anything exists in the vacuum so for
this film
i think we really wanted to pay respects
to what came before
and not just by the video games or the
previous movies but also by what the
fans has contributed to the lore
and the legends of mortal kombat and
that's what kept this
video game series going for more than
two decades i spoke to
robin shaw actually and he's he's such
just the loving humble
guy he totally appreciates what we're
doing and it just makes me
understand that yeah we're actually
standing on the shoulders of giants
because
he did in his time it was difficult and
he was
a rule breaker a pioneer and now it's
for us to actually
broaden that out and carry the dream
with us so it's uh
it's really gratifying to be able to do
that there's a lot of moral combat
characters that we
don't get to see and like this is out
there but like one being johnny cage you
know he's always around
let's say we're getting a sequel do you
have a fan casting in mind of like who
you would like to see play johnny cage
hmm ryan reynolds would be perfect
that's a good one it has to be like
yeah like ultimate like yeah yeah yeah
that's a really cool
actually i love it i think the original
was like based off jean-claude van damme
i do bring in some more female
characters
into the realm though because there's so
many great female characters in mortal
kombat
it would be nice to actually even out
the team a little bit where's my girl
jade i love jade who do you want to
fight in the sequel
who would you want to go toe to toe with
that we haven't seen yet
everybody i i would love to fight kung
lao yeah i think it would be interesting
if
either one of us would choose to jump on
the bat side and then we would fight
against each other
that would be that'd be cool
you